the david pakman show subreddit has been
titillated and abuzz
ever since yesterday's Roseanne Barr
incident where she called me a bully on
social media just hours after getting
fired by ABC one of the discussions on
the subreddit is exactly that Rosanna
calls David Pakman a bully on Twitter
Roseanne you have now officially crossed
the line we'll just wait until the next
segment where I talk about what Fox News
did with regard to my little spat with
Roseanne Barr on Twitter very exciting
yeah if Roseanne's first comment about
Valerie Jarrett didn't get her fired by
ABC this certainly would have yes apps
of calling me a bully on Twitter would
have been grounds for Bob Iger
immediately firing her also on the David
Pakman show subreddit this is from two
nights ago Sean Hannity is losing it
tonight this guy is insane talk about a
bunch of snowflakes yeah when I saw this
I actually tuned into Fox News because I
was so curious and this was in the midst
of the Roseanne Barr thing the
revelations about the michael cohen
shredded documents i mean just every
possible thing going completely wrong
the Trump totally cooked by the North
and South Korean leaders and Hannity was
totally losing it and we know that
Hannity and Trump have a special
relationship of sorts and it was not a
good day in Hannity Ville two nights ago
even crazier that night you would say
because Hannity is losing it all the
time it was particularly unhinged yeah I
mean listen I guess I can't really judge
cuz I'm not normally watching Hannity
but from what I remember he seemed extra
wacky on on Tuesday night also from the
David Pakman show subreddit I would like
David to get more conservative talk show
hosts on the show he always seems to win
the argument and make them look
completely stupid I don't know that
that's how it goes I mean I do think
that a lot of our audience is
predisposed to see my side of a lot of
issues but I am I'm up for here's the
thing about doing the the thing where I
interview conservative talk show hosts
in general the audience doesn't I can't
say what the audience does or doesn't
like but the audience doesn't tend to be
that interested from a numbers
perspective in me interviewing other
political commentators right the things
that seem to do better are inner
with actual newsmakers primary sources
on issues scientists professors experts
in fields when I do the interviews with
other pundit types or commentator types
it doesn't usually do that well with
some exception so that's why I we tend
not to book those types of guests but
I'm totally up for having more
conservative talk show hosts on if
people are interested in that yeah it's
kind of surprising in a way because
you'd think that if they have a big
audience their viewers would want to see
the exchange too if they tell their
audience that they're appearing on the
show which they might not want he does
they may they may not be doing that so
anyway something to think about I'm sort
of open to it and lastly from the David
Pakman show subreddit entitled David
tries to shame a busy scientist for not
clearing a schedule to talk to David for
free so that David can profit this is a
troll on our subreddit what they're
referring to is the other day Pat sent
an email out to Ben Goldacre who wrote a
book named bad science who I reading the
book and I'd like to interview him and
his publicist wrote back basically
saying he's too busy unless we give him
money and we've never paid any guest to
be on the show so I was not pleased with
that so I went on Twitter and I tweeted
to him listen I'm really disappointed
I'm reading your book I think it's
fantastic and your publicist says you
can only do it if we pay you and he
wrote back genuinely seeming sort of
surprised that his publicist was saying
that but still not agreeing to come on
without charging and the the subreddit
user is saying I'm entitled because I
expect him to appear for free it's not
that I expect him to appear for free
it's that you don't really pay for
interview yet I know I either you say as
a guest I want to appear because I want
to have the conversation or I think that
it'll sell books or whatever or you say
you're not going to do it but the I'm
really busy unless you pay me thing is
not something that's very common from
guest I don't think it's about my
entitlement if anything it's about the
entitlement of that publicist to say
unless you can pay
you're not we're not going to do it and
also I was thinking what is the amount
they would expect right we had a
conversation off air because if all they
want is a hundred bucks it's pretty
pathetic to even say I would only do it
if you give me a hundred bucks if they
want five grand
it's just laughable like how would
anyone think that
Ben Goldacre five grand to appear would
be worth it for anybody I was willing to
empty my piggy bank but you were
convincing me that nine dollars and
sixty two cents wasn't gonna cut it no
you changed my mind
if 962 was what it was going to take
then it's pathetic and that's not really
an interview we should be doing anyway
so yeah I'm really entitled for trying
to bring good guests to the audience
what a terrible person I am okay let's
settle back down david pakman.com slash
reddit is where you can participate in
those discussions